Hey hey what's up yeah can you hear me
oh hello I think you hear me yeah I can
hear you can you hear me yeah what are
you watching in the background uh the
trailer for made in Manhattan what is
made of Manhattan with Jennifer Lopez
with Jennifer Lopez yeah okay are you
watching the trailer to see if you're
sold on watching the whole film or uh no
I just get into these like Apple TV
holes where we just watch trailers just
for for hours and hours and hours and
never actually watch anything okay
that's good yeah nothing wrong with that
not at all what are you arguing with
Luis Gomez or that's the best thing on
Twitter is you and Luis Gomez debating a
point yeah I feel like Luis is like
maybe that Simpsons episode where Homer
gets under the argument with a parrot
yes that's that's what Luis is for many
guys every time I see any time I see
Luis post I just hear I can't believe
you go like I'll look at something that
I'm like I wonder if Nick's gonna go at
this and then like you'll go at it and
you'll keep going with it and I'm like
this is wild you know let it go after
like a day I'm like tap down see what's
funny is Luis is still fighting other
people on that same thing
yes yeah yeah currently yeah which one
loose yeah although his nose is fighting
well he's one of those guys it's like
I've been fighting my whole life yeah it
seems noble until you see what they're
fighting for right and one of those guys
is like you know I'm from the street
something I'm gonna fight in my entire
life and what that means is bullying the
people at Burger King because they
forgot to hand him a receipt right so
now he demands an entire refund for his
whole meal right based on the policy he
saw at mrs. Fields Cookies an hour
earlier yeah he's a fighter you know
yeah
he's afraid has morals and he's got
values and he sticks up for them
I love Lois and some of what Lois says I
agree with and then some of it like I
remember that time we were both on and
Lewis was just basically like he was
talking about minimum wage and then he
was basically like his whole concept of
minimum wage was just the word minimum
and he's like right he's like you
shouldn't do the minimum and we're like
no it's not
that it's it's actually it's not just
the word yeah my favorite what I liked
the most about his most recent thing the
idea that like well it was that that you
know the only people that should have
right the only people that should have
an opinion which initially II's his
right I misread him initially right
because I thought his point was that you
know people who who don't have kids
shouldn't talk about issues involving
having kids you know that wasn't his
point you can go ahead and put these
back on it's wrong it's not that you
know that wasn't his point it's that
people with only people with children in
a business should talk about any issue
not just those issues is they're the
only ones entitled to opinion on on
anything yeah right which which is
interesting I haven't I haven't heard
that particular tape before I understand
like to an extent and I understand that
when he's saying that like let's say
like if I lived in a specific community
I might have more invested in that
particular community and I might have
more of an idea of what's going on in
that community but so like my opinion
might be more valid but it also might
not be you know like because I'm so
close to something I might not have a
valid opinion either but yeah he's very
much in the whole camp of like if you
don't have a business which guess
digital technically as a business I know
the FBI and the Attorney General have
their own ideas of what Cottonwood gas
digital is but it is a business and he
thinks if you don't have a gas digital
you shouldn't speak right yeah
well beyond that it's like his analogy
is like cuz I texted him I came and I'm
just like [ __ ] around you know I'm
right and he was like he's like no no I
understand he's like me too dude he's
like we're just having a good talk and
he's like but he's like you know I just
think my analogy of like a poker player
stands and he's like you know if you
don't have chips at the table you don't
have you know you're if you're not if
you're not you have chips in the game
you're just somebody watching the game
and it's like okay well somebody
watching the game still can have an
understanding of the rules of Poker
right right I mean it's like it's not
like people's opinions determine the
outcome of a poker game it's like the
objective like rules and facts of the
game itself right so it's like in fact
like a guy not playing the game isn't
emotionally invested so he's able to
like probably make better decisions than
the person in the game who knows
somebody yeah it's somebody with an
objective view yeah I mean it would
depend I think it's so personal that you
don't know what that guy in the audience
brings to it either but it's like one of
those weird statements is a very Lewis
statement that I kind I see what he's
saying I get it
I think he just wants people to go like
you've done good you're good you know
you did a good thing you have a business
it's great we love you yeah you're good
you have a kid you're not beating your
kid like he goes on Twitter every day is
like I don't beat my kid I'm like well
that's good that's positive that you do
not hit your child um no he's and you
know he's a good dad he's actually a
very very good dad
oh yeah yeah which is good how bad cuz
you look at Epstein [ __ ] were you
surprised when you got rear seat or were
you like not surprised well you know I
mean it's like the thing with Epstein is
like if it weren't for Trump being
elected nobody would give a [ __ ] right
you know and it's it's so funny to see
the narrative on on social media turning
this thing we're saying oh of course
these Trump guys they care about pizza
gay but they don't care about this and
it's like the
Epstein is a central figure to the pizza
gate conspiracy oh yeah huge UBR you'd
be hard-pressed to find people to talk
about pizza gate that aren't talking
about [ __ ] Jeffrey Epstein yeah if
they were pizzas
yeah go go on sir they make they make
excuses for Trump like the the the - I
see mainly are that you know the
prosecutor at the time like in some
interview did say like well I'll tell
you what it with all the people I served
like subpoenas they were talk to Donald
Trump was the only one that picked up
the phone at the time and was like oh
I'll tell you whatever you need to go
you know he was like the prosecutor in
Miami or whatever there's some clip in
him saying that you know Trump made an
effort to help the investigation
cooperate which is interesting not that
it exonerates him for going on the
pedophile plane but now the thing with
the people going on the pedophile plane
yeah
Bill Clinton goes on at 26 times and
then he leaves the Secret Service off so
that's very creepy he's there but I like
there's been other people on the plane
like Chris Tucker
Katie car maybe Katie Couric I don't
really know supposedly Chelsea Handler's
like an associate of this guy
I don't think Chelsea Handler's [ __ ]
underage chicks I don't know like
there's probably some people that are
just in the proximity of this guy and
this might be Trump - who aren't guilty
of the heinous crimes and other people
are well you know me you know I'm not a
Trump guy but sort of leaning into the
idea that it's only elite Democrats that
want to go have sex with children is fun
for me because it hurts them I like I
enjoy that narrative personal yeah well
it's a lot it's a good fun narrative
yeah right and it's it's it's fun to
watch because it's like when you have
back to the Lewis analogy but I don't
have any skin in the game I don't give a
[ __ ] if it turned out the Donald Trump
is like also an elite pedophile it's
like I didn't [ __ ] vote for the guy
I don't care but also Hillary Clinton
murdering children drinking their blood
to cure her Parkinson's I like they were
like what can we can we talk give me
comments on that we we joke around about
that but yeah and I cuz I'm I I
sometimes think about it cuz I did like
a lot of shows with like the Franklin
scandal and like all that which was
Republicans and Democrats it's like it's
everybody um what do you think there's
any chance that you see like Bill
Clinton get questioned or I don't know
if I would say indicted but do you think
that they're dragged into this at all
like what are the chances that they like
face any kind of consequences for this
right absolutely zero very well right
people that like conspiracies and they
like all this [ __ ] what I've realized is
they think it's a show where there's a
series finale and they're gonna get what
they want
like what pop opens everybody gets
thrown in but it's like guys it's not
like that it's just soap opera where you
just eventually don't care anymore and
you stop watching right yeah yeah no
nothing will and nothing will happen
[Music]
it's like I mean I would not be
surprised all these charges and then he
still only gets like six years of
supervised probation right it's like
that it like work release it'll be the
same exact thing again it's just like
you know Madea that like these people
ever face consequences for anything is
just it's a it's a fantasy it's laughing
this yeah right that's the conspiracy
yeah I mean is Hillary Clinton if you if
you if you had to guess and again we
don't have any skin in the game I
consider you a citizen journalist um
yeah you you know podcaster citizen
Journal
if you had to guess like Clinton's
definitely [ __ ] underage girls that
weren't that's the bill 100% right I
mean there's no there's no way with that
without it without a doubt without a
doubt now Hillary what is Hillary doing
do you think she isn't it a weird witch
[ __ ] I think I think she's pretending
like she enjoys doing it to fit in but
she she just wants to be making deals
with John McCain again for yes right she
wants to seem like she's down with
raping children because that's like you
know that's what you want to do with you
that's politics that's how to get ahead
you got to be smarter play the cards the
right way it's it's creepy do you think
we'll see like big-name people get
mentioned like we have chris tucker
already who's somebody that would really
throw you that's like on his plane who
would really shock you well Chris do you
know that's a different Chris Tucker no
I did it
hi that's what I've been told I've been
told is that it's a different Chris talk
oh I was thinking it was weird that you
had I don't think of black people as
pedophiles I don't know why right no
yeah I mean I I doubt I doubt that the
Chris Tucker we know and love has any
idea what even has gone on on Twitter
people are saying he's a pedophile no I
don't think that he's he even knows that
that's occurring right cheese who is the
Chris Tucker then I don't know I've just
been told that you know because people
like it's not it's a different one it's
a different guy
well what about Prince Andrew that guy
is up to its knees yeah it's a different
Prince Andrew that guy is that what is
black that is a black man who goes by
Prince Andrew that's that's a Nigerian
that's a nice yeah I should be clear
that is a black man that's [ __ ] that's
great what
if this goes down the way it goes down
and people get named people are gonna
have to defend themselves from the
allegations that they were [ __ ]
children and that's kind of hilarious as
horrible so it's yes
is there anything funnier than that like
the idea of like these [ __ ] sitting
down with a PR firm like PM k and
hollywood and going listen I just got to
get my side of the story out there yes I
was on the island yes I took the plane
but nothing happened yeah I mean I think
they should get ahead of it and just
turn it in I mean the smart thing to do
is as soon as Epstein was indicted
[ __ ] IRA production company and and
just put it on TV as a reality show
pedophile and that's it that's the kind
of thing that you could easily slip
under the radar of most Americans like
they would you could serve it up to them
under their nose and they wouldn't think
twice about it
oh go Clinton's on a show right you took
you Tony it's Bill Clinton and the black
man from rush hour and have sex with
children but it's a competition
pedophile island you'd have to have
another name for it and then I think it
would be fine like as long as you say
the word pedophile yeah yeah it the
Surreal Life right right it's a real
life season six is just Bill Clinton
having sex with children oh no it's just
a bunch of people sacrificing kids why
does Jeffrey Epstein have that
temperance island yeah unfortunately
Kevin Spacey beat one of the boys to
death he's be asked to leave the island
hang up his Cabana don't worry
later in the season to give commentary
all right hold on we're having a we're
having a tech issue you're breaking up a
little bit here this is probably on I
think it's my fault they stepped I
stepped into the other room that's it
here we go yeah you're good now you're
good now yeah I stepped into the other
room with my headphones on okay so I
went I went out
we'll play one that arranged in my phone
please don't do that again what um what
are you I just think this is so funny
like is do you like the the Yas Queen
like neo-liberal you know people are
already starting to say that this is
like a white supremacist cause like
prevent the kids from getting [ __ ] is
like the new patriarchy whitey prices I
haven't seen that tape but I'm not
surprised
oh it's caught oh it's C I think vice
did a thing and then other people just
jump on it with the lamp well bison I
sort of thing about Epstein back when
the Miami Herald like started breaking
the story again because what happened
was is that you know Acosta was
appointed and anything that Trump does
you know they have to figure out why
it's bad right and and you know and and
unlike like the like typical liberals
they are they don't even do a second of
[ __ ] research to find out if one of
they're like sacred cows has done
exactly the same [ __ ] thing and and
has as policy you know going on the you
know the past like three Democratic you
know administration's or whatever and so
they they jumped on the Acosta thing
because you know in Simon's da or
whatever he cut that [ __ ] deal for
Epstein and then you know you Google
I've seen and all that comes up is old
Fox news articles about [ __ ] Bill
Clinton's buddy Jeff Epstein going to
prison for being a pedophile like Fox
covered it pretty heavily because it was
a way to smear the Clintons you know and
nobody gave a [ __ ] about Donald Trump at
the time so like it you know
if it weren't for that nobody would be
talking about it and now they have to do
this like mental work to justify talking
about the thing in a way that doesn't
validate all of the quote-unquote like
insane conspiracy theorists that they
[ __ ] all over a year ago for like the
pizza gate stuff and this is the other
thing like a lot of the I mean there are
obviously the guy that brought the gun
the P
the gate or whatever it started killing
people like that guy's crazy you know
and he didn't kill anybody why yeah I
know but he's gonna start shooting the
guy who brought the gun the [ __ ]
common ping-pong Pizza right maybe you
got a round off I can't remember that is
wrong for everyone listening to this
that is not what we want you to do well
she's high CBD okay right that guy
[ __ ] insane you know I mean but for
the most part it's like pizza gate is
mostly like a joke like most of the
people that are involved in it as a
conspiracy theory like there are things
that are probably true namely like
Epstein with his like services of
underage [ __ ] girls are being used by
elites because you know why the [ __ ] not
there are the most powerful people in
the world you know why not exploit
people in like a direct face-to-face way
rather than through like their job I
mean it's like somebody that sits in a
[ __ ] office and authorizes like the
deaths of [ __ ] thousands of people at
a time it's like not that much of a
stretch to think like oh yeah I'm gonna
go [ __ ] a boy afterwards you know right
it's right you know yeah but like like
so some of the pizza good stuff like
[ __ ] like you know secret messages in
the menu or whatever like you know
looking at like if you look like [ __ ]
Tony Podesta as the second set of
eyelids it's like alright of that much
but it's also it's like it's it's like
kind of like like you know I mean it's
it's a joke it's like a lot of it it's
like stems out of like that all right
fascination with like meme culture or
whatever so there's a lot of people just
leaning into something that is like sort
of a [ __ ] up conspiracy that is like
you know true like the fact that [ __ ]
Bill Clinton flies on the plane with
this guy and then extra stuff is added
on to it because it's fun Rhino it's fun
and it's funny to say these things or
whatever and like you know like we do it
or whatever we do we do literally the
same thing with like [ __ ] David
Geffen and Steven Spielberg Ryan it's
like our David Geffen Steven Spielberg
pedophiles probably not you
but it's very funny to say you know it's
like it's it's very funny to be like
wiser yeah why is there a boy in the
DreamWorks logo how did he get to the
moon there's five minutes of my act when
I go on the road I tell everyone that
Steven Spielberg's a pedophile love it I
mean it's very they enjoy it ya know
it's very that this guy that made all
these films you love and yes is [ __ ]
kids it's one of those things where it's
like huh didn't see that comin yeah um
no but yeah I mean like but the thing is
is like you've I stood it back in like I
think December they published that
probably some article that's like oh
this like weird connection to Bill
Clinton is like stirring up a bunch of
all right April trolls with an insane
conspiracy theory and then they try to
like they try to extricate the epstein
thing and the connection to Donald Trump
or whatever from all of the implications
of all the Democrats and also like all
of these things that people were saying
about [ __ ] pizza gate and it really
can't be you know like taken out of that
context and and it [ __ ] with them for
you know for the same reason that like
you you bring up like oh well Obama
deported more people than [ __ ] it
trumped it and there was also children
in cages effectively I mean it wasn't
policy to like separate you know parents
from their kids but it's like I mean
you're comparing like Auschwitz the
[ __ ] Birkenau or whatever and like
being like well now it's bad right
because you know there's that you know
they don't have music in the gas
chambers you know and it's like well you
didn't give a [ __ ] about this before and
like you know it's good that you care
now but like stop trying stop making it
seem or like look for a way where you
have no [ __ ] overlap with these
alright guys and you think are like
purely just evil and any any like common
ground in terms of like thinking things
are bad with them you need to like
justify in your head why it's you know
not that it's okay that Bill Clinton did
that but like
no we really need to like hammer out the
connection with Trump you know it's like
IIIi don't know that's that's the take I
see predominantly on Twitter that is
like the most annoying to me at least
yeah
well it's this is you know it's gonna
last it's gonna continue that's gonna
just nobody wants that to end I've kind
of realized that like I I would like it
to end and other people that are tired
of it but nobody is tired of that yet on
that side I think you have to get tired
of it on that side and go you know what
I'm just tired of doing this you know
being like a resistance guy that makes
excuses for ya you just gotta go like
I've done this for years I'm tired of it
it's boring I you know it's like when
you use you like a drug addict for a
while eventually get to a point where
you go or you know or you die but a lot
of people get to a point they go I just
I don't want to do this anymore and like
I read that article about the you know
the amber girl and the other Anna
whatever and it it seemed like oh yeah
it's here like a reasonable article and
I don't know I don't even know why
people are angry anymore I don't even
get it
yeah well yes to do it's like [ __ ]
like I guess like quote-unquote leftist
infighting but I mean the reality is is
that like socialism or leftist politics
in general especially as it plays out on
social media it's just sort of like a
magnet for like insane narcissistic
careerists so it because it like it lets
you be like especially now that it's
like combined with like identity
politics stuff it lets you be like a
scold for both like class-based reasons
and race-based reasons now and it's
attracted you know I don't want to like
mention specific people but like
shittier comedians that had nothing
going on like well you know I wasn't
funny so I just get to be right about
everything
Rob yeah and and you know like they're
always just waiting for an opportunity
to cancel people who are conveniently
always
just in front of them in like the line
in terms of a Sencha nin like whoever
the left media darling is for the moment
in IE well it's the most part like
specifically New York I mean it's like
you look at the people who hate amber
the most and they're like it's almost
like their podcast has one less listener
and you know they're like like the
logical next step in terms of like oh
well who should be like instead of this
person who you have said is bad and
that's I think that drives most of that
like cancel stuff with specifically like
people on the left going after other
people on the left that's why you got to
really appreciate the ethics of people
like Laura Loomer turn of it Lauren
southern you know people that really
they have a code yeah they do have a
code it's a it's a code based on
guerillas I think with Mike now he's the
guy he's out there claiming and Metzger
had him on the other day my friend my
friend called me my friend who produces
Metzger's podcast goes Mike Serna vich
is in my garage uh yeah sort of ajiz
claiming and maybe it's true I don't
know that he's the he's the reason
Epstein got rear ested because he I'm
there I'm the reason right yeah I think
it's come to
yeah Mike can [ __ ] off we did we did the
work that was us you brought we got we
got a little bit of help from the Miami
Herald they did some good reporting Lee
K Brown I think she kind of you scooped
her on a lot of stuff but whatever we
did yeah I don't remember talking to her
but I've heard through certain channels
she's a huge fan of the show yeah and as
a result that's that's where that's
where most of her there she soars most
of her information but a lot of that
stuff I don't know if you read the Miami
Herald
last couple of months but yeah a lot of
it had to do with you know the
DreamWorks logo in my DS about a boy
[ __ ] camp on the food the David
Geffen has access to yeah well they were
posting all of their articles in like a
coke frenzy at 308 in the morning so I
was like oh yeah there's something to
this
yeah right yeah all that stuff in there
about how you know Adams a lot of that
down the F scene rabbit hall
yeah right what do you what do you think
do you think it's gonna get really bad
in terms of like you think now when all
this stuff starts to come out there's
gonna be more guns and pizzerias like do
you think it's just unravels are people
gonna just lose it no I think like
[ __ ] uh like you know I like it you
know be the the ideal situation is like
the the [ __ ] absolute ideal situation
I would love for this to play out is the
court documents are unsealed we learn
more information it implicates like
Dershowitz Clinton's all of these
[ __ ] people
it's like called emmaclaire is a little
Democrats and then and then he's like no
actually I kind of only met Trump that
one or two times you know and it's like
not if there's zero implication to drop
and then a week later like Trump like I
don't know stares at like [ __ ]
waitresses ass and he gets caught on
like camera doing it and then people are
like oh this waitress asked ade is the
biggest scandal of the year and then
like we just completely move on we
completely there's we there is not a
[ __ ] word spoken and they drop the
charges on the technicality and there's
just like just like nothing and then
back into his mansion everything MC goes
back to his mansion Biden gets the
nomination and loses Donald Trump and we
have four more years that's the ideal
res the ideal situation that's there's
nothing better there's nothing better
than that
um yeah enclosed
and thank you very much for doing this
over the phone I appreciate are you
gonna come out here ever for Twitter to
Los Angeles yeah no to Miami so we could
go outside
Epstein's yeah we got us a couple of
crossbows obscene property with
defensive defense self defense crossbows
only I told ray calm down there and run
on his property and just run around
what's the worst that could happen yeah
I'm like ray you have nothing to lose
let them let the dogs go at you a little
bit you know yeah who cares yeah you
should I you should definitely come out
here and we could do like an
investigation maybe we could get to
Spielberg's house I don't know but that
would be great yeah you know we could
yeah if we can yeah if we can rent a hot
air balloon and hover it over David
Geffen's property and use binoculars -
yeah then like maybe like you know just
[ __ ] a loudspeaker and just says if
there's any boys in the house please
come up to the roof and identify
yourself please announce your age on the
roof of this house I feel may be more
than the kids I think I feel for Chris
Tucker the most out of this whole thing
mmm like Chris Tucker is sitting there
somewhere with no clue the people on
Twitter is saying he's [ __ ] kids on a
plane he has no idea he probably hates
you his yeah Chris Tucker is somewhere
with his great-granddaughter and she's
trying to show him tick-tock he's like
he's like man come on you know I can't
be doing no phone [ __ ] and then like
pops out his name is trending on Twitter
[Music]
[Laughter]
come on you know it'll be [ __ ]
[ __ ] alright Nick thank you so much
for calling in dude you're the best I
appreciate I'll see you soon yeah thanks
for having